Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Alessio Politi
Nella vita faccio l'inviato.
Una volta si usava spesso
l'aggettivo "speciale":
forse perché allora lo erano davvero.
E penso ai grandi inviati
come Richard Kapuscinski,
Ettore Mo, Tiziano Terzani:
gente che ha scritto articoli
da tutto il mondo,
e che hanno ispirato
anche la mia carriera,
sognando un giorno
di poter ripercorrere quella strada.
Io, però, non pensavo
di poter riuscire a diventare un inviato,
e questo per un blocco emotivo
che ho fin da piccolo.
Durante questo discorso, per esempio,
la mia voce potrebbe farsi affannata,
potrei aver difficoltà ad esprimermi
per un groppo alla gola.
Oppure, in altre occasioni
comincio a sudare.
Quando succede questo,
riesco a farmi il bagno, completamente,
nei miei vestiti, in due minuti,
e non c'è strategia
o camicia scura che tenga.
Succede quando mi trovo
al centro dell'attenzione,
o in situazioni di forte stress
o disagio, come questa;
o molto spesso -
Quando capita ad un giornalista televisivo
non è proprio il massimo della vita, ecco.
La svolta è arrivata nel 2011.
Lavoravo a Firenze,
e sono entrato in Rai
nel 2008, per concorso.
Il caporedattore viene da me e mi dice:
"Giammarco, vai a vedere
cosa sta succedendo in Lunigiana,
nel nord della Toscana;
c'è un allagamento, dei nubifragi.
Ovviamente non sapeva
che cosa avrei trovato sul posto
perché non avrebbe mandato me,
che ero l'ultimo arrivato, il più giovane.
Sta di fatto che arrivo ad Aulla,
in Lunigiana, al mattino,
e la situazione è ben diversa
da quella che avevamo immaginato:
c'era devastazione, c'erano morti,
c'erano dispersi,
c'erano tre ponti crollati.
I ponti... poi ne riparleremo.
Io comincio a fare
il mio lavoro da cronista,
finalmente su un fatto
di cronaca importante.
Raccolgo testimonianze, interviste.
Rimarrò lì per più di dieci giorni
con la stessa camicia
e lo stesso giubbottino di pelle.
La mattina faceva molto freddo,
perderò anche la voce:
ma questo è un altro discorso,
che ha a che fare
con la vita di noi inviati.
Quello che mi interessa sottolineare
è quello che succederà
quella sera stessa, alle 20 in punto.
Mi trovo di fronte a una telecamera:
quella è l'edizione delle 20, del Tg1.
Il Tg1 delle 20 è l'edizione
più vista in Italia:
sono 4,5 milioni di italiani
che aspettano di sapere
cosa gli racconterai.
Ovviamente ero molto nervoso,
molto sotto stress.
La telecamera si accende
e comincio a parlare.
La mia voce però è calma,
riesco ad esprimermi.
Non sudo:
forse era abbastanza freddo,
era a fine ottobre.
Comunque riesco a portare al termine
quella diretta di un minuto e mezzo,
riesco a raccontare
tutto quello che avevo visto
durante quella lunga giornata.
Alla fine di quella diretta,
mi rendo conto che potevo fare l'inviato.
Avrei convissuto per sempre
con questo problema,
ma ce la potevo fare.
Ma perché intestardirsi tanto
nel voler fare un qualcosa
che mi creava così grossi problemi?
Perché penso che raccontare
le storie delle persone,
raccontare la vita della gente
e raccontare il mondo
sia una delle cose più belle
e più importanti che si possano fare.
E molto spesso il giornalismo,
a differenza delle alluvioni
che i ponti li distrugge,
a volte, e molto spesso, il giornalismo
i ponti li può anche creare.
E ora vi spiego come.
Maggio 2019:
mi trovo a Caracas, in Venezuela,
inviato per la Rai per seguire i fatti
che stavano avvenendo nel Paese.
Un giorno vengo a conoscere una vicenda
che riguarda e interessa 64 bambini,
64 bambini venezuelani
che hanno bisogno di cure.
Purtroppo, però,
quelle cure vengono rimandate
da circa tre settimane.
Questo per effetto di un accordo
che c'era tra il governo venezuelano
e un ospedale italiano
che prevedeva il trasferimento
di questi bambini proprio in Italia.
Quell'ospedale era
il "Bambin Gesù" di Roma.
Purtroppo, però, il governo venezuelano
non stava pagando quei milioni di euro
necessari al trasferimento
di questi bambini,
che non potevano essere curati,
però, nel loro paese
per la mancanza delle medicine
e dei trattamenti necessari.
Decido quindi di andare
a casa di Maria Julio.
Maria Julio ha sette anni, è di Caracas.
Ed è una delle bambine, appunto,
che attendevano queste cure
non più rimandabili.
Ed incontro sua madre
in una casa molto povera,
in un quartiere molto povero di Caracas.
La madre, in quell'occasione,
fa un appello agli italiani,
ma [anche] al mondo,
disperata, in lacrime,
chiedendo di sbloccare
finalmente quella situazione.
Ovviamente io realizzo il servizio,
che poi quella sera stessa
entrerà nelle case degli italiani
con l'appello della madre di Maria Julio.
Poche ore dopo,
il "Bambin Gesù" di Roma
organizza una conferenza stampa
per annunciare che da lì a poco
avrebbe consentito il trasferimento
di questi bambini in Italia
per, finalmente, effettuare queste cure -
e lo avrebbe fatto
gratuitamente, pro bono.
Ovviamente mi precipitò subito
a casa della madre di Maria Julio,
dove si trovava anche
un'altra madre, di un altro bambino,
anche lui affetto da leucemia
e quindi anche lui
in attesa di queste cure.
Dò loro la notizia,
ovviamente loro non lo sapevano.
E questa volta, la loro reazione
è un pianto di gioia, di grande felicità.
Ricordo quel momento
come uno dei momenti
più belli della mia vita.
Purtroppo però, sapere tre giorni dopo
che il bambino dell'altra signora
non ce l'avrebbe fatta,
nell'attesa di quel
trasferimento in Italia.
Invece Maria Julio,
e tanti altri bambini venezuelani,
riusciranno ad ottenere quelle cure
e riusciranno, quindi, a salvarsi.
Ecco: questo è uno degli esempi
in cui il giornalismo diventa un ponte
tra gli ultimi, tra gli inascoltati,
tra chi non avrebbe altra possibilità
per far sentire la propria voce
e chi, invece,
quel potere di risolvere
le situazioni ce l'ha:
i politici, le associazioni,
le singole persone.
Facciamo adesso un passo indietro,
e andiamo nel gennaio del 2017.
Mi trovavo questa volta inviato,
sempre per la Rai ma in Italia, a Teramo.
Sono in compagnia di un collega,
Giorgio Specchia
del Giornale Radio della Rai.
Ci troviamo a cena,
siamo lì per l'emergenza neve
e stiamo trascorrendo alcuni giorni
facendo cronaca, appunto in Abruzzo.
A un certo punto, notiamo un tweet
del presidente della Provincia di Pescara:
è un tweet confuso,
che parla di morti, di possibili dispersi,
di una valanga e di un hotel.
Noi non sappiamo che fare:
decidiamo però di andare a vedere,
sul posto, cosa stava succedendo.
Ci mettiamo in auto
e arriviamo a Penne, un piccolo paesello
sotto il Gran Sasso, attorno a mezzanotte.
Il paese è completamente immerso
nel buio, in un black out.
Ci sono tre metri di neve,
e l'unica luce è in fondo,
ed è la luce
del Centro di Coordinamento
della Protezione Civile.
Ci avviciniamo, chiediamo informazioni,
e ci confermano che una spedizione
è appena partita... su degli sci.
Dei soccorritori si sono messi sugli sci,
e stanno cercando
di raggiungere un albergo
che si trova qualche chilometro
più a monte rispetto a dove ci troviamo.
Quell'hotel, quell'albergo,
è ovviamente l'Hotel Rigopiano.
E queste sono le immagini
che ovviamente voi tutti riconoscete.
Da allora, era mezzanotte,
cominciamo quindi a lavorare
e a dare informazioni su quella vicenda.
Io avevo la prima edizione al mattino;
Giorgio, invece,
andava in onda sul Giornale Radio
della Rai ogni mezz'ora,
e quindi faceva la spola
tra il Centro di Coordinamento
della Protezione Civile e il mio collega,
dandogli le informazioni
su dove si trovassero i soccorsi.
Eravamo gli unici giornalisti,
ma soltanto perché ci trovavamo vicini
quando avevamo avuto questa notizia.
Gli altri sarebbero arrivati al mattino.
Quel che succederà dopo
lo conoscete tutti, purtroppo:
i dispersi salvati sotto la valanga,
quei quattro bambini tratti in salvo;
ma anche le vittime, e poi le polemiche
e il processo ancora in corso.
Ma non è questo che voglio
sottolineare in quest'occasione,
ma quello che succederà
tre settimane dopo.
Mi trovavo a Roma: l'emergenza era finita,
stavo facendo colazione, una mattina.
Apro il giornale, e sfogliandolo
trovo l'intervista a Fabio Salzetta.
Fabio Salzetta è uno dei due
sopravvissuti di Rigopiano
che si trovava al di fuori dell'hotel
nel momento della valanga.
Lui si era salvato casualmente,
in quell'occasione:
e racconta, in quell'intervista,
quelle ore di disperazione
tra il momento della valanga
e l'arrivo dei soccorsi.
"Mi trovavo in auto", racconta Fabio,
"assieme ad un altro sopravvissuto:
avevamo freddo, era -10, -12 gradi.
Eravamo disperati, era tutto buio,
non vedevamo niente,
non sapevamo dove fossero gli altri.
E soprattutto, non sapevamo
se qualcuno sarebbe,
effettivamente, venuto a soccorrerci.
A un certo punto, accendiamo la radio
e sentiamo una voce"
Quella voce era la voce
di Giorgio Specchia,
del collega del Giornale Radio.
Continua Fabio:
"Grazie a quella radiocronaca di mezz'ora,
in mezz'ora noi avevamo la certezza
che qualcuno sapeva che noi eravamo qua,
che qualche soccorritore
stava cercando di raggiungerci.
I soccorritori sono
a tre chilometri dall'hotel;
i soccorritori sono
a due chilometri dall'hotel;
i soccorritori sono quasi arrivati."
E Fabio conclude: "Probabilmente,
quella voce ci ha dato
quella forza e quella speranza necessaria
per non soccombere alla disperazione".
Ecco: anche in questo caso
il giornalismo può diventare un ponte,
un collegamento
tra i soccorritori e i soccorsi.
Tra chi sta cercando un aiuto,
e chi quell'aiuto
effettivamente lo potrà portare.
Potrei continuare a lungo
raccontando aneddoti di questo tipo,
ma purtroppo il tempo è quasi finito.
Mi lascio un momento
per rivolgermi direttamente,
e soprattutto ai più giovani
presenti in sala e non solo.
Non rinunciate mai ai vostri sogni:
cercate sempre di raggiungere
il vostro obiettivo della vita,
anche se dovesse costarvi
un bagno completo nei vostri vestiti -
o molto, molto peggio.
Vi lascio con un brano
tratto da una serie di articoli
contenuti in un libro che si chiama
"Dispacci dalla Cambogia".
"Un giorno, mi imbatto
in un checkpoint di Khmer Rossi.
Uno dei soldati mi vede,
comincia a correre verso di me.
Era fuori di sé, era invasato;
mi sbatte contro il muro,
mi ficca una pistola dentro la gola.
Io lo guardo con gli occhi spalancati
e penso: questo è
il momento in cui morirò.
Poi, non so perché,
improvvisamente, senza motivo,
comincio a ridere.
Una risata a crepapelle, sguaiata.
Quella risata mi salverà la vita,
perché il soldato avrà
un attimo di esitazione necessaria
affinché il capitano del suo battaglione
si avvicini e blocchi l'esecuzione".
Questo era Tiziano Terzani:
un inviato molto, ma molto, speciale.
Grazie.
(Applausi)